[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
[Musik]
guten abend alles hängt mit allem
zusammen die ukraine krise und russland
am gashahn da sprechen wir gleich noch
ausführliche dieser sendung das hat
direkte auswirkungen auf die kosten fürs
heizen im deutschen winter die sind
ohnehin schon exorbitant gestiegen und
sie sind haupttreiber der inflation
schauen wir uns das mal an und 4,9
prozent haben die preise für waren und
dienstleistungen zugelegt im januar
verglichen mit dem januar vor einem jahr
sagen die statistiker heute das ist zwar
weniger als im dezember aber mehr als
die experten eigentlich erwartet hatten
und die allen voran die ezb müssen sich
jetzt fragen lassen ob ihre geldpolitik
noch stimmt das sind fragen die sich
alle in diesem land täglich stellen wie
peter theisen zeigt
die stark steigenden preise treffen auch
in daniels arbeitet als hausmeister
teilt selbständig sowie halbtags fest an
einer wiesbadener schule dass alles
teurer wird merkt er beim einkauf des
materials
die einmalhandschuhe die sind das
doppelte teurer geworden da habe ich
früher für das päckchen 399 bezahlt und
bezahle jetzt 97 bisher gibt ja die
höheren preise noch nicht an seine
kunden weiter doch lange kann er das
wohl nicht mehr durchhalten denn auch
fürs tanken muss der familienvater
mittlerweile erheblich mehr ausgeben es
hat etwas gemerkt dass ich vor einmal
für 25 euro den voll gemacht habe
mittlerweile kommt man an die 40 50 euro
an dann überlegt man auch mal privat mit
der familie weil man mal ein
ausflugsziel anfangen möchte was ein
bisschen weiter ist das machen wir jetzt
mal nicht die inflation auch die mitte
der gesellschaft spürt sie mittlerweile
deutlich
das große problem ist ja dass inflation
wie eine steuer wirkt aber eben sehr
ungleich die menschen trifft weil
diejenigen menschen die vergleichsweise
alles geld für den täglichen konsum
ausgeben müssen die werden von dieser
inflations steuer ganz besonders
getroffen wäre er sein geld erst später
der zukunft ausgegeben wird wir sparen
kann der wird vergleichsweise milde
davon betroffen sein die inflation ist
im januar deutlich um 4,9 prozent
gestiegen
besonders dramatisch die energiekosten
20 5 prozent nahrungsmittel verteuerten
sich um 5 dienstleistungen um drei
prozent angesichts solcher zahlen
fordern sozialverbände die politik zum
handeln auf unsere konkrete forderung
ist beispielsweise dass die
mehrwertsteuer auf frisches obst und
gemüse gesenkt wird damit sich eben auch
haushalte mit wenig geld weiterhin
gesund ernähren können auch jasmin
stitch arbeitet allerdings halbtags und
sie merkt die preissprünge bei den
lebensmitteln ganz klar die
milchprodukte der wocheneinkauf für uns
vier personen lag bei 120 130 euro und
jetzt ganz klar bei 170 euro familie zu
tisch und auf 80 quadratmetern gerne
hätten sie eine etwas größere wohnung
doch dann könnten sie nur noch einmal im
jahr urlaub machen sie leben noch gut
sagen sie trotzdem achten sie auch zu
hause darauf die kosten niedrig zu
halten
ich bring das auch meinen kindern bei
dass wenn wir zum beispiel mal lüften
das fenster aufmachen dann die heizung
runterdrehen den fernseher zum beispiel
wenn wir dann auch nicht da sind dass
wir den standby ausschalten den stecker
ziehen familie zurzeit arbeitet hart für
ihren lebensstandard doch der ist in
gefahr wenn die inflation weiter in die
höhe schießt
frage noch mal nach bei stefanie bareth
an der frankfurter börse gut nahm
stefanie gerade von der europäischen
zentralbank haben ja immer die
beschwichtigung die inflation werde
wieder deutlich sinken geben den
zentralbankern diese neuen zahlen denn
jetzt noch mal neu zu denken die sehnen
sich quasi einen rückgang herbei aber
reichten sehnen ein sehnen reicht da
keineswegs von den europäischen
währungshütern erwarten hier viele am
kommenden donnerstag entschlossene
signale um die inflation einzudämmen
vor allem jetzt wo die us notenbank
konkrete zinserhöhungen angekündigt hat
um der nullzinspolitik und der damit
einhergehenden l geldflut grenzen zu
setzen natürlich steht für die ezb viel
auf dem spiel einerseits könnte sie wohl
mit langsam steigenden zinsen die
inflation einfangen höhere zinsen
bedeuten aber auch höhere belastungen
für die haushalte der verschuldeten eu
staaten und deren schulden sind in der
kurve la corona krise auf ein
bedrohliches niveau gestiegen und eine
neue schuldenkrise will natürlich
niemand registrieren auch deshalb zögert
die ezb und wie geht's jetzt
mittelfristig weiter mit den preisen
spricht er noch viel für diese ezb these
dass sich alle befürchtungen in sachen
inflation irgendwann den luft auflösen
werden also das ezb ziel von zwei
prozent inflation das dürfte tatsächlich
ein traum in werth weiter ferne bleiben
auch wenn der preisdruck her im
jahresverlauf vermutlich etwas
nachlassen wird insbesondere wenn sich
material und lieferprobleme entspannen
viel spricht dafür dass sich die
teuerung hartnäckiger hält als von der
ezb angenommen denn die strom- und
energiepreise dürften auch auf längere
sicht deutlich an der kaufkraft von
verbrauchern lagen fossile energien wie
gas und öl werden eher knapper und
teurer heute schon kostet das barrel
nordseeöl fast 90 dollar so viel wie
seit sieben jahren nicht mehr das ist
auf dem weg zur klimaneutralität
durchaus auch politisch gewollt hat aber
eben auch seinen preis genauso wie die
kostenintensiven klimamaßnahmen auch sie
erfordern massive investitionen am ende
dürfte auch diese immensen afra
nachfrage die preise eher anheizen
stefanie bareth frankfurt dankeschön
heute abend die lage ist verzwickt auch
bei einem anderen gebiet deutschland
möchte es sich mit seinen verbündeten im
westen nicht verderben und nicht mit dem
russland des wladimir putin deutschland
will die ukraine nicht im stich lassen
und die eigene versorgung mit russischem
gas sichern
deutschland will den konflikt nicht
herbeireden und weiß genau dass der
längst tobt in der ost ukraine mit
tausenden toten you can't have you can t
get sagen die amerikaner wasch mir den
pelz aber mach mich nicht nass heißt das
bei uns ein dilemma ganz besonders für
die spd in dem der aktuelle
bundeskanzler seinen außenpolitischen
kurs finden muss während ihm nicht nur
ein früherer bundeskanzler in die parade
fährt heute war krisentreffen an die
künast
es ist alles klar das ist alles routine
es ist
niemand aufgeregt nur die medien die spd
will erst draußen keinerlei
klärungsbedarf haben und dann drinnen
ihr verhältnis zu russland klären
schweigend die ankunft der
außenpolitiker die öffentlich klar sind
und intern frustriert weil ihre klarheit
anderen parteiflügeln unheimlich ist und
unklar wie viele da sind olaf scholz
saskia esken und ich völlig klar das ist
der weg der spd wir nehmen gerne
ratschläge entgegen und das ist auch
völlig okay wenn andere sich in die
debatte einmischen aber die die
verantwortung für die partei tragen die
sind klar und deutlich und
unmissverständlich die führung der
partei unterstützt die führung der
regierung kein nachlassen der diplomatie
keine waffenlieferungen aber falls
russland die ukraine angreift dann
massive wirtschaftliche konsequenzen
keine sanktionen ist dagegen seit jahr
und tag die position nicht nur der ex
parteichefs schröder und platzeck
sondern auch von bundestagsabgeordneten
wie ralf stegner und ministerpräsidenten
wie dietmar woidke und manuela schwesig
tabu vor allem ein projekt
auch im deutschen interesse und auch
andere europäische staaten setzen auf
das gas aus dieser erdgasleitung im
übrigen bin ich davon überzeugt dass es
richtig ist weiter auf kritischen dialog
und wirtschaftlichen austausch mit
russland zu setzen man weiß nicht genau
was die spd heute klärt aber das dürfte
ein punkt sein versteht
dialogbereitschaft die für uns im
vordergrund steht steht natürlich auch
die wehrhaftigkeit beides gehört
zusammen
denn am ende müssen wir ja in den vielen
gesprächen die wir jetzt
dankenswerterweise wieder mit russland
führen auf den preis hin weisen den eine
weitere militärische eskalation
russlands in der ukraine hätte von wem
die eskalation ausgeht auch das muss die
spd dringend klären in seinem podcast
die agenda zeigt der chef des
gesellschafterausschusses von nord
stream 2 nicht auf russland und ich
hoffe sehr dass man endlich auch das
säbel in der ukraine
wirklich einstellt denn was ich dort
vornehmen muss auch an schuldzuweisungen
deutschland wegen der vernünftigen
absage an waffenlieferungen
das schlägt manchmal doch den fass den
boden aus ich bin ziemlich da er auf die
fakten und die faktenlage ist sehr
eindeutig die ukraine wird bedroht und
das nicht zum ersten mal die spd muss
stellvertretend für das ganze land
klären was wichtiger ist werte oder
interessen koalitionsvertrag dieser
ampel regierung steht dass deutschland
in zukunft eine insbesondere werte
geleitet der außenpolitik nicht eine
ökonomie geleitete außenpolitik machen
will und werte sind in europa mensch
schwer unter druck es wartet nicht nur
die deutsche politik auf die spd es
warten viele regierungen freund und
feind auf die versprochene klarheit
der außenpolitische sprecher der spd
nils schmid war heute beim spd-internen
krisentreffen zur russlandpolitik dabei
die ist sehr klar sagt der parteichef
opposition bündnispartner auch einige
parteifreunde haben da doch zweifel ob
die wirklich so klar ist guten abend
herr schmid
und den abend der 7 wie kommt das denn
wie kommt das denn dass deutschland bei
verbündeten in der welt jetzt als
unzuverlässiger partner gesehen wird
nun das hat sicher eine lange
vorgeschichte die auseinandersetzungen
aus trieben zwei hat da nicht geholfen
aber kannst du schulz und auch
parteichef klingbeil haben die letzten
wochen klar gemacht wir stehen
solidarisch an der seite unserer
verbündeten in europa und in amerika und
auch für deutschland liegen alle
optionen für sanktionen auf dem tisch
und das gilt auch für die für den fall
eines angriffs der russischen seite auf
die ukraine dann gehen jetzt doch noch
mal eins nach dem anderen durch auch
nach dem was sie jetzt heute internen in
der spd besprochen haben wird es
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine geben
aus deutschland
ja oder nein
lars klingbeil hat schon in der
bundestagsdebatte klar gemacht das ist
kein wachstum geben wird wir wollen ja
vermitteln im neuen format und da würde
das nicht zusammenpassen und daran gibt
es nichts zu deuteln wird es grünes
licht geben für die lieferung von alten
ddr waffen island an die ukraine abgeben
will
auch dazu hat die spd sich schon in der
vergangenheit im bundestag klar geäußert
wir setzen auf vermittlung auf
diplomatische bemühungen sind vermittelt
zusammen mit frankreich im raum ein wie
fahrrad deshalb sollten wir auch keine
indirekten waffenlieferung beliebige gut
gespielt das ist jetzt aber noch nicht
so besonders viel druck bisher auf
russland deswegen die nächste frage kann
die gaspipeline nord stream zwei aus
russland nach deutschland noch in
betrieb gehen und zwar ganz explizit
diese pipeline und nicht einfach als
teil von alles liegt auf dem tisch
zunächst mal geht ja das
genehmigungsverfahren jede plan musste
europäisches und deutsches recht halten
und ansonsten gilt das was lars
klingbeil im bundestag ist stolz
mehrfach gesagt hat alle optionen liegen
auf dem tisch vom bankwesen über die
energie auch noch sind zwei bis hin zur
persönlichen sanktionen irgendwie war
stets sehr kurz unterbrechen darf der
bundeskanzlerin nimmt die namen der
pipeline interessanterweise in nie
wirklich in den mund er sagte mal alles
liegt auf dem tisch umgekehrt hatte aber
mit der dezember noch gesagt nord stream
2 ist ein rein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt das klang
dann lange zeit zumindest wie das liegt
eben nicht auf dem tisch
nein der bundeswehr so ist ein freund
klarer aber auch knappe worte wenn alles
auf dem tisch liegt liegt auch wirklich
alles auf dem tisch und niemand sollte
einseitig was unternehmen jedoch aus den
25 märz es getan hat alle optionen
liegen auf dem tisch ist es gut dass
putins sich nicht ausrechnen kann was
genau im falle eines angriffs dann
tatsächlich an sanktionen verhängt wird
das gehört zu einer glaubwürdigen
abschreckungspolitik dazu gerhard
schröder wird in verdrehung sämtlicher
fakten jetzt ausgerechnet der
säbelrasseln vor wie kommt dann ein
ex-bundeskanzler dazu so etwas zu sagen
ist das schlicht das geld das er von
gazprom bekommt oder glauben sie er
meint das wirklich so
damit ist sie selber fragen für uns als
spd und bundesregierung ist klar das
muss dann die eskalation vorangetrieben
hat und deshalb muss russland eben auch
in weiß sagen sollte es zu einem angriff
kommen an dieser linie halten wir als
spd die bundesregierung fest und das ist
das was wir auch unseren verbündeten
geben dass die ja völlig auch ziemlich
verlass uns ist und wie wie peinlich ist
das für die spd wenn ein ehemaliger spd
chef und spd bundeskanzler genau das
gegenteil sagt und damit auch weltweit
schlagzeilen macht
natürlich ist schröder könnte schröder
als ehemalige kanzler in der welt
bekannt und ja vertritt seine meinung
aber für deutschland sehr eben das was
die regierung sagt und das ist für
estland wurde auch mehr
vorsitzen nochmal bestätigt aber gefragt
wie peinlich dass für die spd ist
da gibt gar nix da gibt es gar nicht
eilig zu finden sondern schröder hat
seine meinung und das ist auch in
ordnung so aber wir müssen uns jetzt
darf man auch nicht künstlich
distanzieren die spd hatten die klare
haltung scholz hat das war eine klare
haltung ehemalige kanzler kann an der
politischen debatte teilnehmen auch wenn
er nicht mit der richtigen partei führen
schickt die ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg vorpommern frau schwesig
macht allerdings den eindruck dass ihr
die ukraine jetzt nicht unbedingt als
erstes in den sinn kommt hauptsache die
pipeline kommt
nein wir sehen uns alle in der spd einig
von den ministerpräsidenten über die
parteiführung bis in die regierung wenn
das der fall einer russischen aggression
gegen die ukraine hohen preis nach sich
ziehen würde das kein vertrauen und das
was kriegen weil bundestag erklärt hat
wird von der gesamten partei der breite
getragen auch von frau schwesig
natürlich okay dann bedanke ich mich
ganz herzlich bei ihnen herr schmidt
nach stuttgart für dieses gespräch und
dem heute-journal update hat wulf
schmiese fragen an den langjährigen
wehrbeauftragten und spd
verteidigungsexperte hans peter bartels
so ein wichtiges ziel hatte die
bundesregierung den deutschen gesteckt
und sich selbst heute ist stichtag und
man muss sagen verfehlt hannah du hast
die details na ja ganz genau es geht um
das im ziel der bundesregierung und das
ist in der tat nicht erreicht worden bis
ende januar sollten 80 prozent der
bevölkerung zumindest einmal geimpft
sein tatsächlich lag die quote bis
einschließlich sonntag allerdings nur
bei 75,8 prozent
und noch ein weiteres ziel von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wurde deutlich
verfehlt seit weihnachten sollten
eigentlich 30 millionen impf dosen
verimpft werden dass er keine meldet
bisher aber nur rund 17 millionen erst
zweit und dritt impfungen
friedrich merz ist nun auch offiziell
neuer cdu vorsitzender der 66 jährige
erhielt in einer briefwahl
95,3 3 prozent der stimmen märz hatte
bereits auf dem online parteitag vor gut
einer woche ein ähnliches ergebnis
erzielt rechtlich bindend war aber erst
die schriftliche abstimmung
wegen der spannungen zwischen russland
und der ukraine kam heute der un
sicherheitsrat zusammen in öffentlicher
sitzung gegen den willen russlands
der russische botschafter sprach von
megafon diplomatie und einer einmischung
in innere angelegenheiten
die usa warfen moskau aggressions
drohungen an der ukrainischen grenze vor
und beschuldigten russland zudem eine
aufstockung seiner truppen in belarus zu
planen
wegen zahlreicher partys während des
corona lockt downs steht der britische
premier johnson seit wochen in der
kritik ein vorläufiger interner
untersuchungsbericht wirft der regierung
nun führungsversagen und schwere
regelbrüche vor einige der treffen in
downing street number ten hätten nicht
stattfinden dürfen heißt es darin auch
der übermäßige alkoholkonsum dort sei
gebracht johnson entschuldigte sich
mittlerweile für seinen umgang mit den
vorwürfen er kündigte weitreichende
reformen in seinem amtssitz an
die in afghanistan regierenden taliban
soll in einem un bericht zufolge seit
ihrer machtübernahme mehr als 100
ehemalige beamte regierungsmitarbeiter
und ortskräfte getötet haben und das
trotz der angekündigten generalamnestie
das melden mehrere nachrichtenagenturen
übereinstimmend die taliban regierung
wird derzeit von keinem land der welt
anerkannt zu der prekären
sicherheitslage in afghanistan kommt
eine humanitäre krise laut un angaben
ist mehr als die hälfte der bevölkerung
von hunger bedroht
nach deutschland die streifenwagen der
polizei in vielen bundesländern tragen
trauerflor es ist der reale albtraum
aller polizistinnen und polizisten sagt
deren gewerkschaft ein routineeinsatz
vergangene nach den rheinland pfalz
landkreis kusel die streife kontrolliert
ein auto auf einer landstraße
dann können die beamten nur noch funken
die schießen für die polizistin und
ihren kollegen kommt jede rettung zu
spät marion geiger und anna duda
berichten
sulzbach im saarland bis in den abend
sind schwer bewaffnete spezialkräfte im
einsatz
am nachmittag wurden hier zwei männer
festgenommen sie sind dringend
tatverdächtig
der 38 jährige hauptverdächtige andreas
es soll am morgen zwei polizisten in
rheinland-pfalz erschossen haben der
zweite festgenommene bis 32 jahre alt
beide ließen sich widerstandslos
festnehmen
der 38 jährige soll morgen einem
ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt werden
derzeit laufen hier einfach noch die
ermittlungen und die fahndungsmaßnahmen
auf hochtouren wir können nicht
ausschließen dass es weitere verdächtige
gibt
die tat geschah in einem spärlich
besiedelten gebiet viel egger wald und
wiesen säumen den tatort im kreis kusel
in der westpfalz auf der kreisstraße 22
zwischen meierhof und uil mit vielen am
frühen morgen gegen 24 die tödlichen
schüsse eine 24 jährige kommissar
anwärterin und ihr 29 jährige kollege
von hier streife und wollten eine
verkehrskontrolle durchführen sie
konnten noch melden dass schüsse fallen
die verstärkung aber kam zu spät die
brutale tat sorgt bundesweit für
entsetzen die bundesinnenministerium
twittert unabhängig vom motiv diese tat
erinnert an eine hinrichtung und zeigt
dass polizei jeden tag leben für unsere
sicherheit riskiert
als zeichen der trauer sind die flaggen
in rheinland pfalz auf halbmast gesetzt
die landesregierung zeigt sich tief
erschüttert
zwei junge menschen die während ihrer
dienstausübung mit größter brutalität
erschossen worden sind das ist einfach
schrecklich
ich kann nur ahnen was jetzt in diesen
familien vor sich geht die angst wie
trauer des entsetzens aber auch wie
aufgewühlt unsere eigene polizei ist zum
motiv und den genauen ablauf der tat
laufen die ermittlungen
morgen nachmittag soll es eine
pressekonferenz geben mit ersten
gesicherten erkenntnissen
ganz anderes thema jetzt bei uns im
heute schon mal wenn es schneit im nahen
osten dann machen die einen sich auf ins
winterwonderland meist auf sommerreifen
übrigens was das verkehrschaos nochmal
deutlich steigert sie begeistern sich
dann etwa für das seltene schauspiel der
heiligen stadt in weiß
sie fahren ski und snowboard in den
libanesischen bergen pulverschnee blauer
himmel
atemberaubend wie gemacht für instagram
das sind die einen für die anderen ist
schnee in nahost ein kampf ums überleben
allein in syrien sagt das rote kreuz
sind 14,6 millionen menschen auf
unterstützung angewiesen mehr als je
zuvor wer gerade mal ein zelt hat erlebt
diesen kältesten winter seit jahrzehnten
in der region als blanken horror zdf
korrespondent in guinea teil berichtet
die berge westlich von alle wo einst die
antike römerstraße entlang führte sucht
mohammad back ismael jeden kargen hügeln
noch ein bisschen holz ab er ist 17 6
vater ist vor drei jahren gestorben
jetzt ist er der versorger an den
sträuchern und wurzeln hängt das
überleben seiner familie
die berge sind besser zu uns als die
menschen es sind zumindest geben sie uns
was ab gerade jetzt die preise für
zucker für benzin für öl sie haben sich
fast verdoppelt
kein wunder bezahlen sie doch mit der
türkischen lira hier deren verfall hat
so einfache dinge wie eine zeltplane
oder etwas öl für sie unbezahlbar
gemacht
das zählt die bleibe nennt mohammad das
raumschiff das lager liegt mitten im
nirgendwo
letzte vorbereitungen vor dem schnee
mohammads mutter stopft die löcher in
der zeltplane und wo das holz nicht
reicht verbrennen die brüder plastik
auch wenn sie alle unter den giftigen
dämpfen
das holz ist dass es brennt nicht leicht
sagt seine mutter und es macht die hände
wund es ist voller dornen
weiter nördlich hat der schnee die lager
schon erreicht die winter in der region
werden immer härter die unterstände der
vertriebenen immer baufälliger
dieses selbst viel einfacher auf die
leute drauf dann haben sie die kinder da
drin befreit und zu den nachbarn
gebracht
abu salim musste die letzten nächte alle
paar stunden mit einem besen das
zeltdach vom schnee befreien er ist
nervös seine vorräte gehen zur neige und
kein einziger helfer hat bislang seien
camp bereich die kinder sammelt den
schnee zum trinken
seit drei vier tagen haben wir kein
wasser mehr im tank die organisationen
wollten uns trinkwasser bringen aber
ihre fahrzeuge erreichen uns nicht wegen
des schnees
hilfsorganisationen wie hier die weiße
helme kämpfen um die schwer zugänglichen
lager zu erreichen und sie kämpfen um
spenden die reichen längst nicht mehr
alleine nordwest syrien sind 1,7
millionen vertriebene ständig auf
lebensmittelhilfen angewiesen
ich denke die welt schenkt syrien nicht
genug aufmerksamkeit wir bekommen nicht
die finanzielle unterstützung die wir
brauchen letztes jahr erhielten wir nur
45 prozent der benötigten summen
der schnee macht ist eine tägliche suche
nach holz noch schwieriger mohammed
badie es mal sagt noch erwünschte sich
sie alle könnten endlich in ihre städte
zurückkehren und er würde als mechaniker
arbeiten ein unerfüllbarer traum bislang
ganz gehört die spenden reichen nicht
wenn sie den menschen in syrien helfen
wollen dann können sie das über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
das spendenkonto hat die bahn de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 das stichwort zdf
nothilfe syrien weitere informationen
gibt es unter spenden zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
und hier hat hanna jetzt nochmal
nachrichten und wir blicken nach
heidelberg dort hat eine woche nach dem
amoklauf an der universität heute eine
trauerfeier für die opfer und
betroffenen stattgefunden
mit einer schweigeminute am mittag wurde
an die getötete 23 jährige studentin
erinnert aus bisher unbekanntem motiv
hatte ein 18 jähriger student am
vergangenen montag in einem hörsaal um
sich geschossen und die studenten dabei
getötet drei weitere personen wurden
verletzt
danach erschoss der angreifer sich
selbst
für strom müssen die verbraucher immer
tiefer in die tasche greifen auch
deshalb könnte die eeg-umlage nun
deutlich schneller abgeschafft werden
als bisher geplant
bundesfinanzminister lindner sprach sich
für eine schnellstmögliche absenkung aus
und stellt ein ende der umlage bereits
für die jahresmitte in aussicht wenn die
koalition sich darauf verständigen
eigentlich sollte die ökostromumlage
2023 abgeschafft werden
und es gibt eine amtliche
unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes in teilen von
baden-württemberg und bayern besteht
oberhalb von 800 metern die gefahr von
starken schneeverwehungen
wenige tage vor der eröffnung der
olympischen winterspiele in peking
steigt die zahl der korona fälle dort
weiter an erneut wurden dutzende
einreisende positiv getestet darunter
auch sportler und teammitglieder wegen
steigender infektionszahlen hat die
regierung zudem einige wohnviertel in
peking abgeriegelt
unterdessen haben im nationalstadion die
ersten kunden zur eröffnungsfeier am
kommenden freitag begonnen und
damit sagen wir zwei hier im namen des
gesamten heute-journal teams vielen dank
für ihr interesse an diesem montag und
gegen mitternacht gibt es dann unser
heute-journal update mit wulf schmiese
bis morgen und die in allen einen
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
benannt nach dem sturmtief am wochenende
dem tief nadja kam heute gleich das
nächste tief hinterher das tief morgen
übernimmt tief philine und das -hoch
gustav über dem atlantik bleibt weit
abgeschlagen und so ist die pause
zwischen bett und philine wirklich nur
kurz wenige werden merken dass es
zwischendurch mal nicht schneit oder
regnet heute nacht schneidest kräftig
weiter hier in sachsen und auch in
bayern dann kommt ein kleines schneeband
heran und schon morgen früh deutet sich
neuer regen von der nordsee küste an sie
sehen wie das in richtung südosten auch
immer mehr schnee wird die
schneefallgrenze steigt aber im westen
an heute nacht machen sie sich auf tief
winterliche straßenverhältnisse bitte
gefasst hier in sachsen und auch am
alpenrand es drohen schneeverwehungen
und es droht schneebruch es fällt schnee
schneeregen und regen und bei
temperaturen zwischen plus 3 und minus
drei grad kann es überall auf straßen
und gehwegen glatt werden morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen im südosten bei 0
bis 3 grad sonst wird es milder
besonders am niederrhein da klettern die
werte bis 10 grad und auch morgen tut
sich die sonne sehr schwer sie sehen sie
allenfalls mehr hier im nördlichen
brandenburg in mecklenburg vorpommern
oder auch an der nordsee wenn der starke
bis stürmische wind die wolken
auseinander ob am mittwoch ändert sich
wenig der donnerstag wird ruhiger und
freitag kommt schon das nächste tief und
wie sie hier am trend für bremen sehen
können ist ein wintereinbruch auch bis
mitte des nächsten monats nicht in sicht
guten abend